Bạo sống người đi qua đã để lại chết hạnh nặng nè cả về người và tài sản ở nhiều địa phương.
Đặc biệt sù bạo ra đi qua, những lụ quét ngập lột những hư hạ để tài sản,
vẫn chuyến nhiều vứa sân xơi và hoàn cảnh khó khăn, nhiều ra điện với nặng quà mình khóc của khóc quà.
Khóc có tình mình chung cụi mình đủ phía bắt, hàng nghiên gây dân, làm phải hướng chữ thì lại nặng nè.
Nếu dân cả nước có thể chuyển khoảng uống hộ đồng gà của ngủ sâu bạo sống người,
khoảng cụi bắt cửa trẻ trung ngương của y bán trung ngương mà trẻ tu cuối Việt Nam,
tên tài khoảng mà trẻ tu cuối Việt Nam bán cửa trẻ trung ngương,
số tài khoảng chính chính chính, chính chính, hài không, hài nằm,
ngân hàng cứ mạnh của phần ngoại thân Việt Nam Việt Kong Bán.
Trung ngương hội chứ thấp đảo Việt Nam cũng vừa phát gạo chính dịch,
chúng ta y vật lụi từ ngày bà mới thành chính tiến bà mới tham người nặng nình phương trả mạnh nằm,
kêu vọt đồng mà trong nước kêu bảo nước ngoài,
các thử trước xanh nghiệp và tự tâm nặng nhé ấy,
cùng chúng ta y sẻ chia vệ bà con trung lú,
giúp họ sức tử khó khăn uống địa của sống,
thông tin uống hộ, tên tài khoảng, chúng tôi hội chứ thấp đảo Việt Nam,
số tài khoảng, hát hài không, hài nằm, ngân hàng cứ mạnh của phần ngoại thân Việt Nam Việt Kong Bán.